banks in Greece had trans people
everywhere
how many of us in history
trans people people that don't conform
to a single gender across the board I
mean I just I I I'm you might be right
but just because it's not necessarily in
societal terms or even like no like if
you think even about being um like
homosexual for example quite like
homosexuality pretty much quite
eradicated from from society it was only
seen Underground
because well for one colonial law made
homosexual homosexual Behavior illegal
but it took a long long time for gay
people to come out of the Woodworks it
is illegal someplace exactly there were
some there were certain people like for
example there's like a whole um pretty
much a whole generation of like gay men
that just aren't talked about because
that was before
before it was legal when being gay could
still land you in jail what what's your
what's your what's so like trans people
trans people were pretty much eradicated
from the Forefront of society but it
doesn't mean they weren't there it means
that you may not have seen them they may
not have been discussed
we can't prove they were common either
we can't really look into their
conception exceptions but it's not
really I feel like the only difference
is we used to call them transsexuals
rather than transgender but they're like
The Rocky Horror show or they were just
they were just that one yeah that no one
really spoke about they were just part
of society it is older than all of us in
the room so we should take that into
consideration well like across the board
this is a new thing and like it's in the
last hundred years
ago Adam and Eve it was there I guess
when did it when did it come it's new in
a sense where it's been getting more
exposure you know it's more to talk to
us doing it you know and in that regard
but I think that's necessary you know I
think people need to be more aware of
these things I think the movement that
black people had the movement that women
had the movement that gay people had the
movement that you know
I want to take it back well you don't
want to work
well you know I mean I just want you to
be able to advocate for what you believe
in but actually get somewhere if you
don't start to adopt at least some of
the language you're not gonna get
anywhere they're not going to listen I
just think like why should I be forced
to learn this what do you want to win do
you want to get somewhere or do you just
want to insult people because you can't
do it I I don't think it's insulting to
say that I don't well again I feel like
a lot of things are insulting that's
what women do we feel like everything's
insulting so it's like you know we can't
base facts off of our feelings yeah but
do you want to win or do you just want
when I'm just wait though like what comp
these are my options okay I could say it
nicely they're still gonna do the same
thing or I have to live with their
delusion I have to use their language I
have to I have to have them in my
bathrooms and after to play with them is
it really delusional to call them trans
women because they're still not CIS
women they're not biological I would say
if we're having them if we're having if
we're pretending that there's something
that they're not which I I would say it
is women I would say they pretended but
I would say I would say a trans
a dude that transitioned to a woman
sorry
um I would say even though they got the
surgery even though they're dressing
like it they're still not women
but but when you when you put them in
our bathrooms it's like now I have to
pretend and act like it's normal but you
don't have to pretend like that's the
same as us it's up to you because this
is what I would do if if a man walked
into my locker room I would go get the
manager and say get them out but I can't
do that now why do you want to be I
can't do that that's who I am I've been
I've been tattling on this yeah I've
been tattling on on parties you know so
my neighbor throws a party I'm calling
you know what I mean that's I'm not the
food's bad I'll get the I do it but so
now I have to do it different Behavior
based on them based on how they're
dressed you don't have to but I'm just
saying as someone that knows you I'm
like do you want to actually have
success and get somewhere then that's
what I would do but you don't have to do
that I'm just saying do you want to
actually make change and say hey it's
not cool for transgender women to be in
team sports where they have Advantage
for X Y and Z like if you want to get
somewhere you kind of have to adapt at
least a little no there's no winning I'm
sorry
argument sounds like your argument
sounds like blackmail yeah how am I
blackmailing no it does it does it does
sound like blackmail what you're saying
yeah sorry
because what you're saying is that we
have to in order to be okay with trans
trans women and trans men we have to
change our language we have to like no
you don't have to be okay and you don't
have to change your language I'm saying
if you want to communicate with other
people that have this the way that they
are we're like to be fair even I think
like calling a trans woman a man is
transformed if you if you if you
if you if you want change use my
language if you want if you want us to
do what you want you have to use my
language we're being forced okay first
what is being transphobic right it's
just it's as similar as being I don't
know racist you're using inappropriate
language it's a type of prejudice and
you can't just kind of ignore this as
you're trying to engage with other
people on the other side to make actual
progress but the thing is I don't care
what you do do it do what you want but
again it's when you force your opinions
on me but the thing is that's my problem
I think you have a good argument like I
do think within team sports for women
for CIS women biological women whatever
there are some like
um advantages trans women would have
which probably makes it unfair
um so for me the sad part is that I feel
like you're approaching the argument
wrong because I think you have a good
point but it's lost in the language and
it's disregarded because people just
write you off as being transphobic yeah
I mean you can feel that way but at the
end of the day like it's it's really how
I feel like I'm like trying to give you
advice it's very funny how her argument
is very one-sided because she says we um
just because the transgender people
don't like what we say they disregard it
well she's saying we should have history
God no no no what you're saying you're
saying we shouldn't disregard
what the transgender people are saying
to make them feel comfortable but they
should disregard what we are saying just
so they can feel comfortable so it's a
very one-sided that's what's happening
it does happen the other way around like
we we you're already calling them
delusional XYZ like you do this okay I
call women delusional too to be fair all
human beings on the planet are
delusional some way or another if you do
not accept that then you are the problem
more delusional can you can you look at
it from my point of view I'm a young
person right and growing up
there wasn't anything to do with trans
like it's a very new thing it's very
very new to understand how trans people
are like have become if that makes sense
so it is very
hard for someone like me to now try like
change my language and say they and them
very perfect I think if you have a good
intention it doesn't matter too much
would you would you guys think about
people that are religious that you know
they've been raised and their religion
obviously goes back for a very long time
and a lot of people still I'm so I'm
Muslim I don't think I could ever be
comfortable with accepting new terms for
you know like I just I just don't think
I'd ever do it like I don't think I'd
you know I think it's fine if you don't
want to accept things but also you're
not really gonna be able to engage in
arguments if you're not so the point of
arguments and debate is you're trying to
meet someone in the middle so that you
can have a conducive you can't you can't
engage in an argument unless you're
engaged it in the way that I think is
right this is basically no you need to
meet people in the middle yeah but why
don't they mean I don't know but why
don't but why don't they meet her in the
middle probably would meet you in the
middle
not if they don't if not not unless
she's forced to use language that she's
not coming comfortable using which she
just said is there's religious do you
think there's any difference between a
man but we can talk about religion but
that would be a whole other subjects
like any difference at all like can we
not just use it because it's confusing
AF if we don't so transgender woman and
so am I I think it's I think it's more
confusing when you add it on there but
it's not like men men are trying to
compete with women in sports or men men
are trying to like turn off in our
bathrooms and stuff it's there has to be
a differentiation or the com the
composition is [__] confusing no no I
say the men that like that are trying to
be women that's how I would say it well
are trying to be women or transitioning
I would say I would say trying because
you you can't do it yeah
they can't carry children they can't
carry their children they have no
ovaries some biological women have
problems doing that yeah and that like
like I said earlier that doesn't make
them any less of a woman yeah some men
cannot impregnate their sperm for
whatever reason has this one but the
difference is trans people can never do
it that's fine that's fine how many
people how many heterosexual people have
had children
I'm pretty sure every single transition
I'm pretty sure every single transgender
person on the planet was born from a
heterosexual man and woman just because
someone is born man and born a woman it
doesn't give them the right to be
parents too much f'd up stuff happens
because of men and women having kids how
much so much stuff happens like I
haven't seen one case so far
where there's been a LGBT couple that's
had a child and they've become a mass
murderer bombing schools all of the
stuff that you all of the crazy stuff
that happens
I understand like what all the issue is
with you know transgender people when
there's a lot of crazy stuff that goes
on in the world that's not from
transgender or LGBT the lgbts
but I've told you my issue my issue is
that again they're forcing us to live in
their delusion but it's their peaceful
community
okay okay so so if they want to do their
thing in their Community fine I don't
give up I don't care
but the issue the issue is when you got
men coming into my bathrooms men coming
into my sports men coming into women's
spaces and forcing me to pretend that
they're women that's where I have an
issue but that's your Prejudice and
that's the problem
you have to go through that yourself
that's something that you're gonna have
to come through I don't know if there's
been people that have felt the same way
about people of different races you know
you know people that I've got different
disabilities
transition over you know I think they
would feel the same way if I said I am
now black and now I would like all of I
would like to be the head of the black
student union I would like to be the
head of all these things yeah and they
would have to pretend that I'm black I
guess I think and I think that that's
the only equivalent yeah that's right
and you know what maybe in 50 years time
we'll see what science does
if they make a way for that to happen we
can have another conversation but right
now this is the conversation
or it already doesn't exist on a binary
there are intersex people there are
people that have genetic differences
that does fall out of XX and X Y so it's
there is already reasons for why we see
things a little bit differently whereas
with black and white is just like but if
you don't make any sense
if you look on a DNA level those classes
of people are classed as abnormal it's
an anomalies not natural it's not you
know that's the point
do you know what genetic differences
always used to lead to in the past it
was called Evolution
yes and there are genetic differences
that have led to Devolution so beautiful
things
but the point is by natural selection
there are people that have existed that
we're not um I did not fit into the
normal binary system and things like
that have been like natural selection
takes care of things like that naturally
but human beings because of Technology
because of all this advancement we're
not trying to enforce these things that
if we were to leave it to actual nature
it would actually phase out
hermaphrodites as they were called and
we now call them differently have
existed since the dawn of time yes they
haven't been eradicated
Adam and Eve when yeah the point is we
can blame Adam and Eve genetic nature if
you have to leave everything to Nature
and take science out of it and leave
everything to Nature how we're designed
for one eventually in at a long enough
time span
gay people can't reproduce I'm
transsexuals or whatever would
eventually die out if you had to leave
everything to Nature and human beings
when you go to Tampa you're talking
about how many species are there how
many species are there on this planet
where an individual specimen can change
its gender that happens in nature
design human beings are not designed to
do that that's fine everybody can't
change their nature through their mind
yeah yeah in my opinion you know
the whole point
becoming pregnant by herself now this is
a very rare occurrence okay but the
thing with genetics is things are weird
and we we do there is a woman that got
pregnant by herself were you guys
following her making sure that she
didn't go and inseminate herself that's
this is the thing like this story
scientific weirdness is a thing that
happens
just as how twins can like eat each
other and then they have a different gym
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible